[موسيقى]
إذا كانت شمس الصيف تتسبب في
توهج بشرتك في خزانة ملابسك، فقد تحتاج إلى
تغيير في الاختيارات والأقمشة
والأنماط لها تأثير حقيقي
خاصة إذا كنا شخصًا
لديه بشرة حساسة بالفعل أو نتعامل مع
الطفح الجلدي المزمن دكتور كارا وادا  مع
مركز ويكسنر الطبي في ولاية أوهايو، يقول أنه في حرارة
الصيف والرطوبة، يجب عليك ارتداء
ملابس ناعمة الملمس
وفضفاضة، واختيار شيء من
القطن أو الكتان الذي سيكون
قابلاً للتنفس وأفتح في اللون
سيساعد على عكس بعض من  هذه الحرارة
حتى تتمكن بشرتنا من التنفس
والبقاء أكثر برودة، كما تقول إن الجلد يمكن أن
يتهيج بالفعل بسبب العرق مما
يؤدي إلى التهابه، والالتهاب
في بشرتنا هو ما يجعله أكثر تسربًا،
ويجعله أكثر حكة، وهذا
جزء كبير من  السبب الجذري لبشرتنا الحساسة
والأكزيما التي قد نتعامل معها في
الصيف، تقول وادا إنه يجب تجنب
الأقمشة الاصطناعية مثل النايلون والبوليستر والألياف اللدنة
التي قد تحبس الحرارة والعرق،
وستكون الأقمشة أكثر راحة
وستسمح بتدفق المزيد من الهواء.
وساعد بشرتنا على الجفاف في تلك المناطق
التي تصبح رطبة قليلاً
وتأكد من الحفاظ على الرطوبة باستخدام
غسول خالٍ من العطور، يقول الماء أنه حتى
البشرة المتعرقة يمكن أن تجف في الصيف
من أجل الصحة، أنا آندي غايثر